هذا عقود طويل اعتمدت فيها السعوديه سياسه
تقديم المساعدات والمنح دون شروط تجاه
تخيرا الى انتاج نهج جديد يلزم الدول
باجراء اصلاحات مقابل الحصول على هذه
المساعدات ضمن خطوه تهدف الى اشراك جميع
الاطراف في احداث تغيرات ايجابيه
الاقتصاديه وسياسيه
الاصلاح مقابل الدعم نهج جديد تجاه
المساعدات والمنح التي تقدمها السعوديه
لدول عربيه واسلاميه واقليميه شروط جديده
اعلنتها السعوديه على لسان وزير ماليتها
محمد الجدعان تلزم الدول الراغبه بمساعده
سعوديه بالقيام باصلاحات للحصول عليها
خطوه ستغير الطريقه التي كانت السعوديه
تمنح بها الدعم والمساعدات طوال عقود
الماضيه بهدف دفع الجميع لتحمل مسؤولياتهم
الاقتصاديه والسياسيه فوازير الماليه
السعوديه اكد ان السعوديه لعبت ادوارا
هامه في تحفيز الاقتصاد السعوديه اولا
والاقتصاد العالمي ايضا لكن على الجميع
القيام بدوره وذلك في كلمه له خلال
مشاركته في منتدى باب الاقتصادي العالمي
في سويسرا
ونريده ان يكون مثاليا ونشجع ايضا الدول
المجاوره انت تقوم باعمال اصلاحيه نحن
الان نغير طريقتنا في تقديم المساعده
وتطويرها وبحسب ما ذكرت منظمه التعاون
والتنميه في مجال الاقتصادي فان السعوديه
تحتلوا المركز الاول في تطوير المساعدات
اعتدنا تقديمه من نحن ومساعدات مباشره دون
شروط ونحن نغير ذلك
الجدعان اشار ايضا الى ان بلاده تفرض
ضرائب على شعبها وهو ما يتوقعه الاخرون
فلا مساعدات دون جهد واصلاح يذكر ان
السعوديه عملت على مدار سنوات على دعم دول
مختلفه سواء عبر تقديم المنح والودائع
والمساعدات دون اشتراطات معينه حيث احتلت
المركز الاول في مجال تطوير المساعدات
وفقا لمنظمه التعاون الاقتصادي والتنميه
وعلى سبيل الذكر الى الحصر اعلنت السعوديه
عن دراسه لزياده مبلغ الوديعه المقدمه
لصالح البنك المركزي الباكستاني الى خمسه
مليار دولار اما عربيا فقدمت السعوديه
خمسه مليارات دولار كواذيعه ندى البنك
المركزي المصري بهدف دعم السيوله
فيديوهاتنا الكاتب الصحفي جاسر الجسر حيا
خلصت الجاسر
اولا لماذا تغير السعوديه مسار تقديمها
للدعم الدول المجاوره الصديقه والشقيقه في
هذا التوقيت هذا المساله تتعلق به تصحيح
مسار سعودي ام ان حال ربما من الاحباط لدى
السعوديه اليوم بان هذه الاموال تنفق ربما
في اماكن يعني ليست ذات جدوى او بشكل سلبي
ربما كما يرى البحر
منذ الطبقات رؤيه المملكه 2030 قامت
بالعمل على كفاءه الانفاق المالي
تحقيق التوازن المالي ترويع المصادر
تدقيق حتى الفساد بجهود ضخمه جدا
لحمايه وصيانه الاقتصاد السعودي وبالتالي
تنميه وقدرته على النمو هذه المحصلات
تتعرض معها مساله المساعدات لان كانت
تتغادر يعني هذا الجهد المتحقق وهذا
الوفره التي تتحقق تذهب بالتالي لمساعدات
عشوائيه غير مجديه نظافه هذا النمط يتعارض
اصلا مع رؤيه المملكه 20 30 لانه المملكه
تقوم بالتخطيط في كل تفصيل صغير صحيح
وتدرس بدقه وانا سواء حتى في اتفاقات
الدوليه والخارجيه
تقوم على حسابك متى يتم مساله المساعدات
مفتوحه ومهمله وغير منطقيه انا اعتقد
الخطوه تاخرت يعني لكن يمكن كان هناك
رهانات على من تتحقق شيء لكن هي كان
المفروض تتزامن هذا الخطا مع بدايه
الانطلاق الرؤيه وتقنيها بهذا الشكل اليوم
لما تاتي المملكه هي حصيله لنقل كما ذكرت
جزء من الاحباط لانه كل هذا الضخ وكل هذا
الدعم والمساندات لا يحقق اثر ايجابي في
المكان المستهدف وبالتالي اليوم مثل ما
يفرض البنك الدولي الان لما يقدم قرض
لدوله يضع معايير وشروطه وقولي اصطلاحات
المملكه لا تريد تدخل في شؤون الداخليه
تريد حمايه الطرف الاخير هي خلينا نقول
بشكل هي تفعل هذه المساعدات هي توانس
نهايه تعطيها القيمه الاقتصاديه وتعطيها
القيمه التنمويه بدل ما تكون هاجر مالي
فالتاسيس انه نتعاون نحن نوقف المساعدات
لن نغير المساعداتنا لن نتراجع عن دورنا
الريادي لكن سنقرن هذه المساله انتم
بالتالي في الحاجه في الحاله انت محتاج
لهذه الخطوات لنقل ونتا ان هذا المال يذهب
بشكل صحيح وبالتالي لا نستغط على انفسنا
في الداخل بينما منهج هذا المال في الخارج
بالتالي ما النتائج التي ترجوها السعوديه
في هذه الحاله في السياسه الجديده من هذه
الدول التي تقدم لها الموسم
يعني تقنين الانفاق وقدرته هو تحويله الى
اداء فاعله وكذلك
الامر الاخر المملكه جزء من سياستها
العامه وكما لنا الامير محمد بن سلمان
منوره تكرارا تحقيق التنميه والاستقرار في
المنطقه فبالتالي الحاجه ان تكون هذه
الدول الاخرى التي تتقبل المساعدات
وتصيلها المساعدات السعوديه انت تعمل
بمسار موازي يحقق هذه النتيجه لان هذه
التنميه لا يمكن تتحقق في السياق القائم
الحالي اذا لم يكن هناك صناعه حقيقيه
فبالتالي هذا تحفيز وحث يعني الدول ان
تقدم المرئيات ولن يكون المساله اعتباط
تكون على دراسات ماذا سيحدث بالضبط فاذا
كان هناك مبلغ محدد لدوله في حاجه ليست
مثل سالب ونفس الهنا فقط عن جانب الاخر
مساعدات الاغاثيه والانسانيه المسار
مختلفه لا علاقه
انسانيه يعني نتحدث عن المساعدات التي
والودائع التي تضخ في بنوك بالتالي ممدوده
الان نحن بنتكلم عن عداء السعوديه اذا لم
تحقق في مصادر ذاهبه اليها قيمه حقيقيه
وتجميد وخساره المال السعودي خساره لهذا
الماء الموجود بدلا نستثمر في التنميه
ويستثمر في المواطن المقيم ولا يحقق
الغايه للدوله المستهدفه
معالجه ومراجعه هذه المساله مهمه وتنعكس
اجابه عن الدول نفسها قبل ان تنكسر
القنوات بعد ذلك ستتغير يعني لن يكون
الاتجاه بشكل مباشر لهذه الدول ستكون هناك
قنوات وسيطه قبل ذلك يتم التفاهم معها ثم
بعد ذلك همم الى هذه الدول ممكن يعني
مؤسسات ومنظمات الدراسه والتقديم
والمشاريع المقدمه من الدوله نفسها
فبالتالي ثم العمل على فرزه وتحليلها
واعاده تشكيلها ومدام ملائمه الالتزام
فيها وقد تكون تحدث اخطاء في المرحله
الاولى لكن بالتاكيد في المرحله الثانيه
ونمر اكثر
الجدعان في همم الوزير وزير الماليه
السعودي محمد الجدعان قال نفرض ضرائب على
شعبنا ونتوقع من الاخرين فعلا الامر نفسه
ان يبدلوا جهدا نريد المساعده لكننا نريد
منكم الاطلاع بدوركم سريع ماذا يعني
بمعنى انه يعني المملكه ليست همم جمعيه
خيريه المملكه كما ذكرت سابقا قامت في
اجراءات كثيره في الداخل ومنها ضرب
قيمه الضريبه المضافه على المواطنين
والمقيمين داخل المملكه لتحسين كفاءه
ولمعالجه شكلاته الاقتصاديه فبالتالي انت
احنا متضخم مساعدات عشوائيه غير مقننه
مفتوحه مهمله ليس لها قيمه رصد فانت تعرض
رؤيتك الاساس وانت تستسلم مع نفسك في
الدرجه الاولى لا تتحقق الوضوء الان لا
انتم ليست فقط المساله الضريبه بشكل تحديد
المطلوب انما ما هي الاجراءات التي تكون
فيها لتحقيق حصانه اقتصادك داخل المحلي
التي ممكن تكون هذه المساعده قوه دافعه لك
وقوه ضامنه وتساعدك على تجاوز الماسك بشكل
نهائي وليس فقط عمليه التردد هو مؤقته او
يعني معالجه مشكله يعني قلت في بدايه
حضرتك انها السعوديه تاخرت فيها هذه
الخطوه هل يعني ذلك بانه
من الصعب اليوم
الذهاب في خطوه كهذه من قبل الدول تعودت
خلال العقود على ان تاخذ هذه المساعدات
هذه المنح دون اي شروط فبالتالي هل هذه
الدول قادره بالفعل على ان تجاري المملكه
في في هذه المتطلبات اليوم اذا جازلنا
وصفها بهذا الشكل
النهائي يمكن لا يكون بالنسبه للسعوديه
هذا قرار السعودي بحث نحن سنقدم المساعدات
بهذه الشروط والمساعدات لن تكون ليست
قليله ولم تتراجع اقصد المبالغ
فكره المملكه في دعم تنميه المنطقه سيقوم
على فخ القوه الحقيقي لما يحقق هذه
الاسرار لان المملكه عمليه تبادليه
التنميه تنميه تمتد تنميه اثر فيها هي
ذهاب وليست خط واحد فبالتالي تنمي في بلد
ما هي تنميه العكس على الجميع بما فيها
المملكه هذه التقنيه اذا اذا دوله ثم لا
ترغب او لا تستطيع او لن تتمكن هذه لو
قدمت لها المساعدات المجانيه للمبتغير شيء
لم يتغير
هذا هدر وهمان ايضا جزء من مسؤوليه
الحكومه تجاه شعبه وتجاه مواطنيه اداراتها
الماليه لموارد الدوله يعني ذلك ستغض
النظر ربما عن غيره المبطنه من اي الدول
يعني
تتحدث عن انزلاق في مسارات فوضى في غيرها
من الامور في توجيه رسائل لدول خليجي هنا
نتحدث عن دوله بعينه ولكن نتحدث عن بعض
الرسائل التي قد
او التي شاهدناها في في ايام سابقه في
فترات سابقه وقت من الممكن ان نشاهد مثل
خلال تصور الشخصي خالد انه قد يكون هناك
بعض الحالات لتدعي معالجه خاصه رؤيه ستكون
حالات محدوده ونادره وفقا لظروف خارج
الاطار وخارج التحكم والسدعين مثل الحالات
الانسانيه بعض الحالات السياسيه مثل
الحالاتفيه تتطلب عمل خاص ومسار مختلفه
لكن في الاطار العام لا اعتقد هذا التزام
من المملكه بهذا المسار وسيف تم تحديده
وتقرينه على الجميع ويتم التعامل على
اساسه وفق المنظمات التي تقرر ماذا قدم
ماذا سيقدم وكيف ستثمر هذه المبالغ وما
مردوده الاقتصادي على البلد وبالتالي
تحقيقه امريكا اشكرك شكرا جزيل